Pretender conversation let you know when
you watch TV in the weather presenter in
the news presenter have left fake shell
at the end England Reba Reba
yeah okay interesting that's an
interesting equation you were telling
the other who was okay hello everyone
the cameras there we mustn't look at
ourselves hello hello everyone I'm Brady
from numberphile and this is dr. James
Grove oh hello James is in loads of
numberphile videos he's the most
frequent guest and rid of me have you
read it like any one of our most popular
guests as well and I know a lot of
people were really interested to hear
from him we've been filming upstairs at
numberphile HQ making about five or six
videos we did yes I think we did about
five or six videos that we've recorded
which will be appearing on numberphile
in the weeks and months to come
but while James was here I told many of
you yesterday I thought I would take
advantage of the fact he was here on
Valentine's Day yeah yeah he sent it a
bit odd that we're spending Valentine's
Day together Lee it was yeah it was an
unfortunate scheduling it was the only
day you were free it wasn't what you
mean unfortunate and what do you mean is
there any day I'm free I thought that
wasn't that was this is going down here
let's stop that altogether let's talk
let's talk to James about the things you
want to talk about a bunch of people
posted questions yesterday so I'm going
to ask a few of them so those people
have a chance to be involved in case
they're not here and obviously you can
post questions yourselves now we'll be
following it and I'll try and get some
of them to James as well the first thing
I thought we should deal with is I know
a lot of people may be aware and some
people may not be aware that James has
his own YouTube channel he's been doing
this far longer the numberphile has
existed
it's called singingbanana because it I
don't want to talk about it too much
because I would rather you all watched
my channels than James's channel but a
lot of you asked about it so I'm not
going to ignore it and it's full of
excellent stuff there are three things
that came up most frequently okay the
first thing people want to know is why
your channels called scene banana and
then can you also tell us a bit about
the future of it because obviously with
all your commitments it's a bit more
sporadic and it's uploading what's
happening with it what's the status of
it and lastly a lot of people have asked
you do that and I do my things on
YouTube how did we come to meet bar and
so can you tell people of it I mean I
know the answer to that question okay
all right but okay you can tell people
those three things okay so so I do have
my own YouTube channel singin on of
course it is why wouldn't it be called
singingbanana no singingbanana is my
online name and it has been since I was
like 17 so by the way the search for
singingbanana if you find another
singingbanana online don't harass them
because it might not be me I know
there's some other people who've decided
those two words together would be fun
but it's my online echo my channel
wasn't meant to be anything more than my
personal YouTube channel so that's why
it's called singingbanana and I've been
doing it for five years now in March it
will be my fifth year from measuring for
my first maths video what were the other
questions I was asked you asked about
your future for what's the situation
right now because you obviously have a
lot of things on the go so I do it in my
spare time I don't want people thinking
that I do this for a living so not the
you chance opposed to me yeah exactly
exactly like so my youtube stuff is in
my free time and the more I do a public
talks and the more traveling I do and
the more numberphile I do unfortunately
it affects what smite my singin on a
schedule which is a shame and I don't
like that ayah and I want to do as many
as I can as I can what was the other
question
what's one other happy you were doing
that how do you come to be involved with
number five well I know in the first
case I was a fan of periodic videos so I
saw what you were doing for chemistry
and I wanted to do something like that
for maths um I try to sort of do it on
singingbanana
in my own small way and if you go back
to an old singin on a video there's even
one where I recommend channels and I
recommend periodic videos and I actually
say he Brady's doing for chemistry but I
want to do formats so that such best
facts actually there and so now I'm
doing formats what you want to look what
names with you
oh yeah exactly this is brilliant and I
was a big fan of your Bible Dex channel
as well which also about each book of
the Bible because that's something I
don't know about chemistry physics I
kind of know and I was something that I
didn't know anything about at all so I
was fascinated by those videos like and
like an ordinary you are and I sent you
a couple of nice messages I think saying
I'm loving this channel yeah I live it
if you ever think of doing Matt's
ask me about it I so that opportunity
came up and you did I did you only asked
me about it I did our we went we went to
the pub didn't--we and I said I'm gonna
do a math journal what do you think and
uh yeah you were on board
yeah worst thing you ever did you can do
it no no or the other way around
well no I'm we're very glad to have you
in our yes a few other questions there
are loads coming in so I will try and
get to some of these someone hits
someone asked are we both redheads or is
this strange lighting in that room look
this is not ginger this is brown look at
my abut this is brown with blonde parts
in it that it just comes out a little
bit rusty yeah and someone else has
asked where your accent is wrong my
accent is Nottingham because I'm I'm
from Nottingham originally finally I'm
for those who don't know I'm based in
Nottingham that's where I work on
numberphile James actually was in
Cambridge now yes so you are in
Nottingham today by a map I am born and
bred Natyam and I left when I was 17 as
but I I am this is a Midlands accent
it's a fairly neutral accent maybe on
the side in northern fact its side
things and if anyone's really confused
because I said I live in Nottingham I am
from Australia originally I don't have a
Nottingham accent we had quite a few
questions people asked a lot about your
background
but in particular quite a few people
have asked about what you did for your
PhD you obviously have a PhD can you
tell us a little bit about your research
what your your hardcore math was right
so my PhD here if I start off in broad
terms it was about something called
group theory group theory is part of
maths which is about symmetry so it's
the maths of symmetry and so if you
imagine a square like that and if I
rotate this
we're a quarter-turn you get square
again so that's like ordinary symmetry
if you flipped the square you get a
square again if I rotate to the square
four quarter turns I get back to where I
started so things like that that's the
symmetry of a square but mathematically
speaking symmetry covers a lot of sins
symmetry means there's something we care
about that we want to stay the same so
it might be shape it might be volume or
length or angle there's something we
care about that we want to stay the same
that's group theory and my PhD was about
group theory and it was about turning
groups which is an abstract thing into
matrices which is a concrete thing about
making a bridge between those worlds
there you go that's a start that's the
start my PhD and we can get or we could
go much deeper than that well we might
we might come back to it depending on
what everyone asks about I'll ask you a
couple other things from yesterday and
loads of what were your favorite school
subjects were you into mathematics at
scope so we at school a table when I did
my a level so that's when you do and 17
to 18 years old you start to pick a
levels in the UK I picked maths physics
and chemistry
now maths and physics I picked because
I'm lazy right those are the subjects
that were easiest for me to do actually
I wasn't going to do maths my maths
teacher made me do it he said you are
doing matter said I don't know I did not
see said you are doing that so I picked
maths physics chemistry chemistry was
the one I found hardest but fascinating
I was absolutely fascinated with
chemistry 90% of my time was spent
trying to keep up with chemistry because
it was the one I found hardest to do and
then 10% my times doing maths and
physics because it came naturally to me
so the answer is I'm slightly lazy I
picked the subject that came most
naturally to me but then I continued to
do it and at university that's where I
really started to see the beauty of
mathematics cuz real mathematics that I
care about
about proof and that's what you get to
do at university that's when you start
to be really creative about mathematics
that's why I continue to do it it's the
proof proof is pretty well finally you
should say that because a question that
has come in recently is what
mathematical proof is most surprising to
you or maybe just interesting can you
talk about a proof that is worth talking
about we can weaselly we did film we did
a video about a brief today didn't we
but maybe we keep that one a secret okay
so we're like a song you have to keep up
with a syphon what mathematical proof
there are some things that are
counterintuitive and so those are
fascinating the ones that you don't
expect now those are fascinating because
those are peculiar maths is intuitive
and I want people to understand that
maths is an intuitive subject what you
believe to be true more often than not
actually is true and that's how maths
works
mathematicians are not just working
through the steps they're actually
making creative reliefs creative jumps
so this is how it should work this is
how it should be so now I have to prove
that it is so you're using your
intuition to guide you so the majority
of maths is intuitive in that sense so
when you get the counterintuitive ones
that's why mathematicians like talking
about them I don't give people the wrong
idea but that's what that is but then
you get problems I come yet the Monty
Hall problem which is that which is a
game show where you have three doors you
have to pick the car and then the game
show host reveals one of the doors you
got two doors left and if you change
your mind you're twice as likely to win
and that's very counterintuitive very
bizarre and then you can prove that that
is true mathematicians like to talk
about those strange ones I do want to do
that for numberphile but it's one of
those things has been done so many times
I want to do it in a new way and the
outside of whatever it is famous and
it's famous for a reason because it's
good and you actually learn something
when you start to see the proof you
actually learn something from that
uh you talked before about a levels in
school someone's asked here what grades
you got an a levels what were your high
school marks like well you know it's
gonna be you know it's gonna be a yes I
got A's at a level in my day
where's my pipe in my day we didn't have
a stars for a level so I had AIDS
heydon't okay and a few people have
asked about your IQ have you ever liked
you tester I have yes what'd you get
what's your number so I cute okay I will
do this
however IQ is not a good measure of
intelligence and I'm long to do a bomb
but I'm not a big fan of it
my IQ when I was 16 when I had it tested
was 155
that's really high isn't it yeah it
would put me in that top something
yes 155 and then I and I don't care cuz
I'm still an idea if my IQ was 155 I'd
have it tattooed on my forehead but
anyway I'll never want to mention that
again okay the I'll ask you a few random
ones which is cuz I like questions like
this someone asked do you have a
favorite mathematical symbol and is
there a mathematical symbol you'd like
to change for some reason I don't know
whatever reason would be but maybe cuz
it's hard to write or it's a it's a pain
in the backside and and okay so there
are some course at infinity the cool
symbol mean I might as we get at that
mean tennessee's and it has it has an
implication going forever like a robbery
so there's a kind of a it kind of
there's an intuitive sense of what it's
what it means so it's a well-chosen sin
I like that one once I don't like
because in mathematics we use Greek
letters a lot that's what Greek letters
that I can't write I all the Greek
viewers now will mock me but I can't
there are some Greek letters I just
think I have to write them on sixty
symbols we have a lot of Greek letters
come up and it's a real pain trying to
find them and work with them so I feel I
apologize to Greek viewers well and
you've got a hundred fifty-five IQ so if
you can't tell what's happening mr.
Fusco is there a practical use for
Graham's number
alright so Graham's number
with this massive famous massively
number em it came out of a practical
problem it was a mathematical problem
but it did come out of a problem so I
guess it is born of a problem le and the
problem was about him taking the graph a
graph is a network of dots and lines
that you joined together you take a
graph and how many ways that can you
color a graph and it was born out of a
problem like that and networks and
graphs have very practical uses in
things like the on the internet and how
you join things together networks
together so I guess I guess it does have
a practical use a lot so it's not like
some guy has made up this crazy number
then so now what can I use it for
exactly right exactly like I mean it
could you could do that by just adding
one adding two yeah no it's famous
because it has a real use and at that
point it was the biggest number that had
ever been used in a genuine mathematical
proof at this point because I'm gonna
have a quick read of some of the
questions began because it is
Valentine's Day hmm you brought
something along with you we have made a
video about these numbers on this before
featuring James was one of our earlier
videos so go and have a look and I'll
put it in the video description later
but these are really nice maybe you
should show these holding up to the
camera and you have a chat about them
okay so what I've got here these are my
amicable number okay can you see that
it's even yet that's focus there we go
is my amicable number broken heart
chains so that's 220 on that one can we
get a focus 284 on that one and so the
factors of 220 add up to 284 while the
factors of 284 add up to 220 so they
come as a pair and in the past these
would symbolize your mutual friendship
perfect harm harmony and love and so for
Valentine's Day they are you know really
sweet you know it's a kind of a nerdy
thing but it's
it's a really sweet thing so we had
these made to 2008 four key rings that
join up so you can give keep one and
give the other half to your true love I
guess can can one obtain these only you
I shall shall I shall I shall i yes to
be can obtain these em I have no
commercial interest in this whatsoever
looking but if people would want to know
how and I'm shy doing it but Matt Parker
and myself now Matt Parker's and number
another numberphile speaker Matt Parker
myself we're we're friends in real life
as well so we we set up a little little
company a little business thing where we
were selling these amicable number key
rings and other things as well couple of
maths
things that we came up with that I
thought would be fun and other nerdy
people might like it is called maths
gear I don't know if I if I hold this up
they brought that just because that's
what that was in you bring up yeah
that's that's the packaging yeah so
Matt's gear and Matt's gear calm and
yeah we sell little bits
yeah we're not trying to diss some we're
not trying to be rich if I mean we're
trying to sell those for Valentine's Day
this is probably the worst possible time
to do it forgets because it's too late
you got you've got a year to get in your
your hearts for next year's Valentine's
Day how's that for poorly timed
advertising cool got loads of questions
coming in what do you enjoy doing
apart from mathematics okay so my
hobbies and these day because I spent so
much time traveling and giving talks
it's difficult to do my hobbies now a if
you follow my Twitter I often talk about
films and things cuz I'm I'm just
sitting around in train stations
watching films some a big film fan and I
used to love dancing I used to ballroom
dancing jive dancing and so I can dance
a little better to do that but it's
difficult to do it these days and
juggling is my big hobby I'm a juggler
and so I yeah I juggle clubs and balls
and knives and fire and rings and you
know I ride a unicycle and then it's one
of my things fair enough
that's obviously someone knew that
because one of the
questions we've been at I was asked to
ask you was is there a theoretical limit
to the maximum number of moles one can
juggle so they obviously knew you're a
juggler oh that's an amazing coincidence
so theoretical limit there should be
really no theoretical limit if say we
had a program of a stickman you know
juggling balls you know any his my hands
can move as fast his life and I think
there are programs like that and so
there'd be no theoretical limit because
you throw them higher but there is a
physical in it so the record for
juggling balls I think it's 13 it might
be 11 clubs then it's a little bit lower
so that'd be 11 or maybe it's 9 I
thought I might be higher than that yeah
cuz I think so so they'll but the balls
I thought might be hard all you thought
you the L you feel the balls might be
higher yeah yeah I think it might be 13
I could be wrong about that but it's not
as high as you think it would be uh
because of the physical problem of it
and then then as a friend of mine say
I'd have to credit my friend here a
friend of Mark Michael Colin right he's
a mathematician and the Joker as well
and he says that the world record for
juggling chainsaws is three because yeah
the given chainsaws you're gonna juggle
three of them okay while we're quickly
doing a few personal things about you
because people obviously have an
interest I was asked to ask you your
favorite song favorite song is I want
you back by the Jackson 5 I'm a little
bit camp sometimes I'm a little bit come
you said it sometimes I have do you have
a favorite shape favorite shape not
really not really the sake of an answer
let's say the circle cuz it's you know
it's the limit isn't it of obvious
triangles in your squares do you have a
favorite Doctor Who alien I'm not asking
these questions this is you guys uh I
can okay I can tell you that my students
I used to call me the master
and the master is dr. Hughes enemy the
master is a Time Lord in Doctor Who and
he's Doctor Who's enemy and they used to
call me the master because when my hair
is short and I'm wearing my black suit
as I like to wear a black suit I looked
like or they thought I look like John
Simm from Doctor Who who placed the
master so when I discovered that they
were doing this I was quite amused by
that and I I came in the next lecture
and I tested my microphone by tucking it
and the Doctor Who fans will know what
that means I got someone squeal I got I
got a squirrel for my knee for my
students tick and you got a completely
blank look from me know you don't know
know you're talking about do you have a
favorite mathematician favorite
mathematician okay all right there's on
my office wall there are three
photographs of mathematicians there's a
picture of a man called Alfred young who
was the father of what I study in
particular and many people won't have
heard of him he lived about 100 years
ago and there's a picture of Tom Lehrer
Tom Lehrer was a mathematician and a
satirist in the 1960s a comedian usually
do satirical songs and I love him I
think he's great the fact that he's a
mathematician is just a bonus he's
brilliant and I've got a picture of him
: and the third picture is a picture of
Johnny ball Johnny ball was a he had a
TV show about Matt's when I was a kid so
he was enthusiastic he was a maths
communicator and he wanted to you know
he loved maths and jumped up and down he
wanted to show you maths and he inspired
me to continue to do maths and show an
interest in maths when I would not have
had exposure to that sort of thing
before
and you may be able to see that he's my
inspiration and why I do what I do now
and maybe even be able to see that
so many people have asked to see you
juggle that we're gonna have to do it
got I've only got some cricket balls and
baseball's here so what do you want to
baseball's and a cricket ball yes I'll
try to keep them low as well you will
there you go
what's the great right so I get my
excuses in now if you do elder not only
do it so that's you know simple stuff
but Unni oh yeah
oh hey what you know I'm in first
all right hello I drop up no here we go
hey here we go you'll see one on the
outside guy well well yeah I'm nervous
when you throw the cricket ball in my
direction it's completely under control
we'll have to get you doing some more of
your elaborate juggling for a video
we'll find an excuse sometime we'll see
that up alright let's get back in our
position after that little interlude
favourite number four Yuva number cause
everyone asks your favorite and then I
don't really have a favourite now what
if I said choose a number or I'll throw
this book okay
in that case I will choose the number
one where would we be without the number
one fair enough the next question was do
you have a favorite number between one
and a hundred so you've also covered
that so so well done I'll cross that off
the list
do you wanna quickly just tell people
what your current job is a lot of people
would have seen we made a number file
video with you in which you were
showcasing the Enigma machine yes and
that is a big part of your job as well
your real job so maybe you want to tell
people with your real life job is these
days okay they're coming back later
yeah go ahead so my real job so what my
day job is I travel the UK and I travel
the world and I give public talks about
maths and I'm trying to inspire I'm
trying to motivate people and you know
you might be Anna might talk to children
and I might talk to adults and it might
be in schools and they might be in
universities they might be in festivals
enigma is the one I like to talk about
most so we have that machine
on loan to us and it's one of the most
inspiring and fascinating and brilliant
stories that I love to tell and that's
the majority of my time I do that a lot
how you have an Enigma machine that's
been lent to you or to the yeah the
machine I show off belongs to Simon
Singh and Simon Singh is an author of
popular science books and he lends it to
Cambridge University who lend it in turn
to me so that I can show up and tell
people about it do you like games do you
play games and I'm getting you mean like
online computer games oh I don't know
that let's let's open up to everything
first of all do you do play computer
games what computer games I play
occasionally something I'm a casual
gamer I play the 10-minute sort of games
so like your Angry Birds and I've got an
Atari that you plug into your TV and I
play space invaders top rolls for Atari
well it's one of those again that they
put it inside a joystick so you put it
straight to the TV cool I got my Super
Mario on it and space invaders and
Galaga I like Gallagher I'm a demon or
Galaga you can't beat yet and uh do you
play what do I call them real-life games
even like a real life I don't know what
you called those other night what were
you saying tag non-electrical games do
play you know what I'm asking that's
other question
um oh oh like yeah monopoly there we go
I saw I can think of board games or
role-playing games things like that okay
so I'm not really in that world so I
guess not
role-playing and board games oh yeah hi
friends that do that I'm not good into
any sports or anything you look any
sports ah yeah there's a game you told
me you play all the time if you count
yet I play sport if you count bar
billiards as a sport you're like really
obsessed with the audience you always
talk to me about it you want to make a
video about it I do love to make a video
about poverty it's an awesome what is
bar billiards for those who target so
billiards you know so you've got pews
and a table and billiard balls and so
snooker is a sort of billiards game and
pool but bar billiards is you got yeah
cupboard balls you have to get them into
the holes the holes are in the table the
lot pockets at the sides during the
table you get points so you score as
many points as you can and you have to
score as many points as you can in 30
minutes and it's awesome
it's brilliant people have asked if you
play chess and if you have a preference
for chess or draughts
I guess chess really but I picked it I
do play chess not that brilliant it I
used to play chess with my dad a lot it
was a nice thing we used to do we used
to have a chess board in the living room
and yet a counter that was white on one
side black on the other so we play a
move and then walk away then the next
next day we could come in and go let's
see okay we would do that I really enjoy
doing that people have asked whether or
not you read the comments and the chats
and things underneath videos you're
obviously in lots of videos your own and
numberphile do
do you read comments I read I read all
the comments on my own channel comment
and the messages I get and I'm not
always able to answer them all even if I
didn't mean I I just don't have time to
answer them all I'm sorry and then on
the number fire ones I check yes so yes
I uh I was considering denying it
because they've kind of makes me less
cool but now I check I don't check them
up Cecily yeah you go away what are you
pointing out baby they there is someone
commenting with using your face and the
name James grime on YouTube and we
should point out that is not James that
is just some Huawei I won't use
unsuitable words but that's someone who
is not me who is being creative and
that's not James and people I personally
I think people should be doing that but
Who am I I'm just some guys there you go
someone asked a question about like and
that is when you like your life is so
much maths and mathematics do you like
find yourself just doing it with
even meaning to like counting the number
of times you chewed that sandwich and
looking at looking at a shape or a house
and thinking about dimensions and
equations does it no not really I mean
what we talked about those vampires and
arithmomania and things like that and
accounting to them instead and that's of
your condition of people do that and I
don't think mathematicians as a rule are
have everything Romania I certainly do
not but maybe you're asking me important
terms do I look at the world and see it
as equations and things like that and
you know well but yeah I probably do not
I mean I'm not going so much for the
personal questions cuz you know but a
way from numberphile you're your own man
but I do have to I do have to ask what
pajamas you wear to bed ha ha ok and
just because I didn't expect that
question most of the questions I can
expect but all right ok well I guess I
am I'm I'm considering lying but I'll
just tell you the real answer so I
because I like spider-man so cool no I
just I just wear the t-shirt that I'm
wearing during the day and then I've
never seen you in a t-shirt you're
always wearing to show us this to you
okay I'm not fair enough um a lot of
people of us do you have a preference
for base 12 base 16 or decimal base 12
base 16 or decimal I do you know what
preference I'm quite convinced by the
base 12 people and I like I like their
arguments the not Grande
yeah it's doesn't change mathematics in
in a ground way in a fundamental way but
the day-to-day use of it I do actually
agree with them I wish we did have base
12 time would still be the same but it's
weights and measures should go back to
being base 12 and if it brilliant if
you're quite new to numberphile we did a
base 12 video with James on it
talking about the pros and cons of using
base 12 and again well worth a look
after this and I'll put a link in the
video
and because I like them I'm going to
give those guys a plug that was the was
it Dawson or Society of America we have
a twitter account as well I have to
watch them on Twitter and every day they
give you a natal base 12 fact and I
really enjoy those well I do one every
day that I hear pretty much I should do
one every like 12th day or something
like it gave me 12 hours oh yeah that
the about that's a better idea yeah okay
do you have a favorite branch of
mathematics maybe you could quickly run
through because I think it's really
interesting and it's not something we've
talked about in numberphile the hell is
mathematics broken into groups at kind
of their academic level like in
chemistry we have organic and inorganic
and physical and things like that how do
you break math up and then what's what
do you like so maths is broken up in the
same way as chemistry's so math is
broken up into well we got pure math to
start with pure math and that's what I
do I'm a pure mathematician pure maths
and then that's broken up into algebra
and analysis though I do algebra and for
from my point of view I think algebra is
about looking at the big picture is
about large mathematical objects whereas
analysis is about the details so it
looks at the real numbers and it looks
at those in details I'm all about
algebra and analysis and their
statistics which I'm a big fan of
statistics probability statistics and
then this mathematical physics and
things of that nature which which I
don't really do mathematical physics ok
yeah I'm cool with that
there's been a bit asked and you
probably are a good person to ask about
this because you spend so much time
going to schools and meeting students
and we've done a few videos on sixty
symbols I think it was that I did some
videos about education and how
mathematics has this reputation that
sort of permeates society of maths is
hard it's almost been joke isn't it that
oh this is oh no I've got math math is
Oh heart and it puts people off there's
a real stigma attached to it what do you
think about you know the state of maths
education
the reputation of mathematics at that
level of people who are just kind of
crucial parts of the larger so this idea
that math is hard that's certainly a
cultural problem so it's not true in
other places and in other countries and
things I hear it's a boy subject or as a
girl subject this isn't this is a
cultural thing and there's absolutely no
reason for that but there is that
reputation I don't want to speak out of
turn
I'm not a maths teacher I'm not a
teacher I don't want to speak for those
I I am what I am I am a I'm an academic
who sometimes I I work with children and
I enjoy dinner and so I don't want to
speak about turn but there are dark
things that can be done I don't know
though a lot of people who care about
maths education who are you know that
there are things that can be done you
know what could be done and they are
trying to do that and in a small part
I'm trying to do that too by showing you
know how much can be inspirational
motivate people I have my part as well
but there are better people who
understand the problems better than I do
and I don't want to speak out of turn
few quick ones pie or tail mmm do you
know what numberphile is slightly
convinced me because I before your
numberphile clientele one the one with
an Professor Moriarty in it yes Phil
Moriarty yeah those guys I was thinking
pie what there's no there's pie spine I
mean there is absolutely no reason I to
change the towel yeah it makes it makes
sense as it is and then Professor
Moriarty said one thing that's convinced
me it was at hours a full turn and then
you get a quarter turn a half turn
pretty course of a turn how is a turn
yeah that convinced me for the first
time really I was
I was pretty ambivalent about it but
we'll get that - what a great
advertisement of the video I hope you'll
all go and watch afterwards and I'll put
the link below and Professor Moriarty
will be over the moon with your
endorsement how many digits can you
recite party I'm not putting you on the
spot someone just up to this up to the
counter calculated a length I guess
3.14159265 four I don't know I don't
know so long
I'm sure we'll hear about it if you got
any others wrong favorite food favored I
like Chinese oh yeah yeah there's a
really good Chinese on the corner yeah
there is um you're going back to
Cambridge any but if you want to stay
for Chinese with you know all sort
you're it's up to you favorite color and
nothing in particular
nothing yeah no I like yellow why it's a
bright colorful color and I I like the
bright I'm I have short attention span
and I like bright shiny things yellow
sunshine yes okay uh can you solve a
Rubik's Cube yeah how quickly yes but
badly you know I've got one yeah I can
solve one in about four minutes I'm
afraid I'm not clever we're not gonna
we're not gonna make you do no I I knew
the beginners method and and it takes me
a long time but I learned I learned to
solve the Rubik's Cube not as a kid so I
learned to solve it because I use it as
a prop as a visual aid to teach group
theory which is such as my area of maths
and and the Rubik's Cube is an is an
application of group theory so I learnt
it as a prop uh I'm not very good at it
this is an interesting question answer
carefully favorite youtuber what you
what YouTube channels do watch it that's
other loads it's interesting to hear
about yeah go ahead
do you want to do science ones of the
nonsense ones go it just says if the
question just as favorite youtuber so no
you go ahead
I say oh that's so Gradius either no no
no you okay stop no no no no no no
see periodic videos you can just say all
my channels as one Bible Jackson teacher
I looked and the mass channels and I
hope they don't know like this and cause
we know by heart is a brilliant channel
yes and the other seems like Khan
Academy and come on my favorites that
are less well-known is Tae Yong
he's a math teacher in Seoul in Korea
and he does mathematical puzzles and
things Taeyang T y y8 and Empire and dr.
James stunt a phantom so I always get
his s mixed up dr. James Taunton I think
he lives in Australia now and he cast
some fascinating brilliant videos I love
him and people be less aware of him and
then if we talk about non science and
their maths
I've lots a big one some that are less
well-known we're about to run a pattern
I've gotta go say hello to my friends
hang on I've got a power cable we're
about to rather power alright
I've been talking too much no no do you
know what it was my fault let me start
by said oh I must make sure I plug the
pairing and then I didn't we just got
the permit or change angle this is
putting a little bit more prominence on
I love on me yeah a couple of friends I
want to say hello to a DJ I am a
youtuber so I do have friends and miss
mag 8 to 2 the magician hello ericsurf6
hello another another favorite channels
I have a community channel Natalie NAT
right I am absolutely in love with NAT
ok well now you brought it up I wasn't
gonna bring it up but you say you're in
love with someone but there have been
loads of questions about your
availability or otherwise I'm just
saying there's been loads of questions
you can say what you guys are the office
or they just questions I I wouldn't I
wouldn't say they've been offers there's
just I don't know if it's just a kind of
a curiosity with with other intent or or
not I'm just saying there's been lots of
questions and I'm not saying anything
well then Alex yeah Here I am this is me
have you ever been to the
for tower I guess that asking that
because of the Eiffel Tower this is
actually my office of course so that
would have nothing so yeah you should
ask Brady and I haven't been to the I
don't never been to the Eiffel Tower
no I'm been to Paris look at this face
it's very nice mate it's very close to
here I mean I grew up in Australia and I
went to the Eiffel Tower um well that's
a good question to ask you next then
favorite country to visit because
obviously you have been out of the
country
yeah even if you haven't been to France
which is like a stone's throw away
favorite country and some of my favorite
countries are like Austria and and I
like Scandinavia as Sweden and Denmark I
lived in Denmark for about eight months
I didn't know that yeah and yeah I tell
I Iike dogs that's really the same for
the same same same from me yeah a lot of
people actually I know we're doing I
know these what's your favorite things
are a little bit boring but we get asked
them a lot so I should ask them I guess
a lot of people have asked about your
favorite TV show or favorite TV show and
I've also asked what you think about
some TV shows that involve numbers like
things like numbers yeah night numbers
prepare I I've actually got limbus on
DVD I've got the box set so I travel a
lot so I get box sets and I watch a lot
programs or some traveling and I've got
lumbus I've actually seen the first
couple of series I'm told the first
couple of series is the best and it goes
downhill so that's I got not to look
forward to and I liked what they did so
they were showing mathematicians not as
these people who can't communicate who
are antisocial and all those horrible
cliches for mathematicians between a
mathematician who was yeah brilliant and
perfectly sociable and how his maths
could help in in the Sherry's help them
solve crimes but and the mass was good
maths it's all genuine maths and it they
had mathematicians help them come up
with ideas and check it yeah check it's
good so it's got a bit of a thumbs up
them yeah like I like numbers well what
I've seen
so far the someone if I can interrupt
slightly yeah someone has asked why I'm
with you possibly having a Chinese and
not and not with mrs. numberphile on
Valentine's Day and this is a fair point
so this is and you've mentioned some of
your favorite youtubers so this is a
chance for me to get a message out if
you would like to subscribe to a channel
and make mrs. numberphile very happy
subscribe to Kylie Caravan Kylie Kyl ie
Caravan CA are a you know how spoke
Caravan go and subscribe to it and then
there'll be this big it's a brand new
channel and I'm helping make the videos
so it's got that touch of class about it
but if there's a sudden spike in
subscribers on there because of all you
guys that wall that will be Valentine's
present a taking care of Carly care of
him getting back to getting back to the
man how you fit by the way James has
been like ridiculously sick for the last
week and a half that's the reason he
wasn't able yet to take part in our this
is a good biggest hot biggest prime
that's why he didn't take part in that
biggest prime video and it's amazing
that he's even come here today to help
out and like you've been really
struggling during filming and this is
obviously the webcam is just brought you
to life so kudos to you for yeah I'm
doing this
I stopped to theater isn't it but I was
it I was really disappointed not to be
in the prime number video last week I
really did want to be enough oh I like
that
do you prefer even or odd numbers that's
a good question ah even that a fact that
I said that was a good question birdie
uh do you know what off instinct even
numbers what does that say about me
you're like even numbers I'm I like I
like order I probably would have thought
you'd say even because you see your
favorite color was yellow you're more
kind of the happy nice you're not you're
not an edgy odd number phone kind of guy
off-kilter doesn't yeah do you have
someone has asked do you have your own
channel for those who didn't see the
very start and for those who don't
already watch Jones's other channel it's
called singingbanana
and he's been doing that for about five
years now and it's it's a next
watch my videos first yet but if you
want to see James's own channel and him
doing a few of his own things you can go
and get singing yes it's homemade as
long as you've also subscribed to Carly
get it read because it's about time
reduce your expectations with it's a
homemade channel yours is more it's more
it's more like like you know old school
YouTube I might've thing yeah like like
I'm just a bit unjust like youtuber I'm
around one of you can i there's another
question that's come up a couple of
times it's a question for you but it's
also maybe the birth of a future video
I've been thinking about anyway and I've
been wanting to talk to people but
anyway some people have asked what math
or mathematics jokes or one-liners and
that you like and don't like and I know
you love corny jokes but I'm thinking we
should do a mathematics joke video so if
you've got any maths jokes that you like
or don't like put them in the second
Brady put them in the description he
loves them but that's no but I think
they make a good video but you I know
you like a corny joke and you must know
a few other in here you know and take
epsilon less than 0 they go that's one
for the Mathmos what did you say take
epsilon less than 0 that is killing in
all the mass departments across the
world they that is slain really that
they are loving that it's about going
down a storm let's have a look at their
current James are you really singing
banana is that it you know you are yeah
I am the single banana channel I am
singing about if you see a comment by
singing banana that's me I'm not a
singing banana myself I'm just his agent
why do mathematicians always confuse
Halloween and Christmas is that a math
joke yes because because up 31 equals
Dec 25 that's good that's good that's
the kinda stuff nicely level you're not
working at it that's actually good but I
also don't mind that you know you know
because seven eight nine five jokes
I like those corny ones too but that I
quite liked um do you watch Tara oh
brain O'Brien's
school of hard sons which I've never
seen yeah I've seen a couple of episodes
I've not seen them all I've seen a
couple of episodes daraa obreon is a
comedian in the uk's irish himself and
and he actually did a maths degree in
talented mathematical physics so he said
it's fun a mathematical background he's
got a TV show in the UK called heart
school of hearts sums it's mixing maths
with comedy it's also with Marcus the
sort or who's a mathematician he's great
as well I've actually helped them out a
couple of weeks ago and they wanted to
do something about enigma machines and
codes so I went down and and helped them
out I'm not on Teddy they didn't want me
on telly they didn't want this on TV
I phoned them up and actually sabotage
you because I'm trying to get you on
next clue stivity I'll shake my fist and
so but I I did help them out the Enigma
machine when that is aired I don't know
when that's going to be the Enigma
machine is the one I look after
responses I'm seeing and the stuff that
Marcus says this kind of stuff I fed him
as well so hello to Marcus and dal I
don't think they watch numberphile
person there you might be surprised
they're like I know I know their
producers do - still I do but I don't I
don't know you may eevee surprise
yeah the producers dude that I am Marcus
said get James in because he has an
Enigma machine
they said the producer contacted me they
said hello Marcus said told us to say
hello and she knew who I was I said I do
this thing called numberphile and she
watches and she was she didn't quite
connect my name - to me but she's Lee
actually watches - so hi a question just
because this has been asked so many
times I probably should ask a lot of
people want to know if you play
Minecraft I think I've heard of it as
obviously I don't play minecraft sorry I
don't
Sarah we're all friends here someone
says this is a good question are you
creative right I see right do you know
what that's kind of leading me down
there kind of a downer road where
there's a speech down this road without
maths being creative and go on then
maybe I'll make it simpler to say yeah
from my point of view
maths is a creative subject I mean
creating new mathematics is mathematics
that's never been done before
original new mathematics is a creative
process you don't do that by just being
a robot by being a machine I truly
believe that and that's something I want
to show people as well tell me a bit
about how a mathematician is creative
then right so when I discover something
yeah I discover something new so let's
say I want to prove something ok first
of all I had to come up with a
conjecture right right that's a leap of
intuition is that like a hypothesis yes
a hypothesis is that crease as a leaf of
intuition that's somewhere I want to get
to and that's a creative intuitive thing
but then to prove it I'm assuming that
other people have not yet been able to
solve it so you're solving problems that
other people could not solve right and
that's amazing that's brilliant and
solve it you might take something from
over here you take an idea from over
there and then you put these things
together you put them together in a new
way in a way that's never been done
before and you create something you
create something new something that's
never been done before
cool yeah and then that's true forever
that's one of the amazing things about
it as well someone has to know how long
the stream is going to be they could
watch it all day that's up to you Brady
well it's that well I don't know you do
have a train to catch and there's even
less you're going to stay around for
that Chinese but we won't be able to go
for too much longer they're not too much
like maybe five minutes fun yeah let's
have a look do you prefer hot or cold
weather I did at cold weather they get I
prefer sublimity there's a surprise Brad
an answer for that one
good do you like sushi I don't think
I've ever tried it I'm sorry you've
never had sushi nothing I have never had
sushi and you've never been to the
Eiffel Tower I've never had sushi at the
item tire that's why you should do
though okay awesome um is there going to
be a crime conjecture
groan conjecture there's a growing
cautery is that another grinder is that
yours nurse me that's the crime crop
what what is it it's only there'll be a
fun it any little thing bet them there
was an episode of Futurama where they
were swapping brains have you seen it
I haven't no all right so they had a
brain swapping machine to the swap
brains the swap mind that they couldn't
swap them back once you swapped comes
back one time to so they were all
swapping brains right and they're all
mixed up and they go oh no how are we
going to get back to where we were
because you can't just reverse the steps
yeah and so and this is brilliant the
guy who wrote the episode was a map it
was a math graduate himself Akhila
you've got Kira and he actually wrote a
theorem and so that too so you could do
this in general and it's in the X egg a
really small shot on the blackboard in
the cartoon and how to do it in your
night another made a little and it's
true and it works and I made a little
conjecture about it well in that example
that was a in Futurama he could have
actually done it in few on you in fewer
moves and and it sounds like a
numberphile video it's a little fun
thing that sounds like it could be a
number file video tell you what we'd
better wrap things all right but uh
we'll read through all the comments and
things that you've written later on and
I'll certainly go in and have a chat
when when I get the chance it's not
always easy to reply to comments in
these different comments sections but I
think we'll find a way to do it and
James may or may not as well his
username is singingbanana
yeah and don't forget there's this other
idiot who's using James's picture and
calling himself James grime and writing
here and if you see him like do what if
you can what do you call it a flaming
more Thummim down or make sure everyone
knows that that guy's a bit of an
impostor and yeah I don't know hang on
don't set the young groom up on him no
no no no yeah sorry don't don't be angry
but don't let other people think it's
James because you know because not James
is seeing banana as you know and don't
forget to subscribe to
the caravan and make my Valentines Day
much easier ah thank you glad to help
thank you James for for coming along and
as I said we filmed a bunch of
numberphile videos earlier as well so
you're gonna be seeing plenty of James
even though I'm not going to be seeing
much of James over the next month or two
yeah you'll still be seeing him on
numberphile I'm not seeing him because
he's just really busy with work so but
we'll catch him again in the middle of
the year but you will keep seeing him on
the far and uh it's good fun action
engine did you enjoy yeah it was good
fun yeah you know I'm my own favorite
subject so I could have done that yeah
till the cows come home but I think
now's a good time to wrap it up cool and
we'll be doing will hope to do more of
these kind of things both with James and
with others and with multiple people
because it's good fun it's really good
fun talking to you guys in real time so
cheers everyone thanks for watching see
you later